uh so uh my objective for this talk is
to make this the most valuable talk you
watch at pi data global 2021 as measured
by your team's productivity in 2022.
so what's the big deal about agile i'm
sure you've heard of it it's a big thing
71 of organizations were using it and
this is 2018. uh 90 of companies who did
try it said that they benefited from
adopting agile six percent of those
companies saw revenue and profit growth
after using it and agile projects as
measured by pwc are 28 more successful
than traditional projects these slides
will be made available i'll tweet them
out after this talk and these are all
linked and sourced so you can dig into
these stats
so here's the outline of the talking to
talk about motivations what is agile how
do we actually go through it it's more
of a what do i wish i'd known a year ago
when i was just starting to apply it to
our data science teams
so motivations this is one of my least
favorite questions as a consultant when
a client says how long is this thing
going to take and i'm like oh i don't
know and they say come on ballpark
because this is a recipe for unhappy
bunnies the date comes along we're not
ready the client's upset they've made
promises my team is upset because
they've worked overtime uh the way we're
working just isn't working uh and so
there are all sorts of ways of doing
this can't we just get better at
estimating people are bad at estimating
for example the sydney opera house
estimated to take four years seven
million dollars it took 14 years 100
million even when you can throw all the
best consultants at projects we just
have a habit of going over time over
budget so maybe there's another way so
here's my journey into agile six years
as a principal aid sciences coefficient
and only in the last year about a year
ago i read a book i read this i really
recommend if this is one thing you take
away go get this book it's fun uh it's a
it's a novel about it and devops and
it's a bit too close to the bone if you
work in corporate i.t
so in 2021 i find myself managing three
data science teams up to three workshops
a day through coefficient multiple side
projects and also running the company
and the one-to-ones and
all the finance and legal stuff that
comes with running a company
and i think the thing that made this
work for us was
really going deep into agile
so i'm just going to say this now
there's a load of the stuff that we have
learned way more than i can fit into 30
minute talk is behind this link this is
the first time for this talk only uh
that we've opened up basically our own
internal playbook as to how we do agile
so check it out uh so first of all what
is this thing
let's go through some terminology
there's a lot of buzzwords are they
needed i don't know but we need to know
the buzzword for me to teach you this so
agile it's just a system to manage your
work using time limited iterations those
iterations called sprints one two four
week cycles and you're delivering
working increments what does that mean
it's output that can be tested or
reviewed so if you're building an etl
pipeline then by the end of that sprint
someone can actually review a partially
working etl pipeline or if it's an
analysis there's some analysis some can
review and feedback on the whole idea is
to get feedback from your stakeholders
from your managers whoever it's going to
sooner because they might just flag
something that puts a real spanner in
the works and it's good to know these
things sooner rather than later then we
talk about stories a story is a single
unit of work usually completed within a
sprint for me this is 20 minutes a few
days of work so that's what we call a
story and then an epic is a collection
of stories related together this is
actually a really nice way of organizing
your work i don't see a lot of data
science teams necessarily organizing the
work into stories and epics i think it's
great because if we've got the epic of
improve the marketing team's data
capacity uh in q3 2021 as an epic and we
can see all the related epics going
about the last couple years i am laying
the breadcrumbs for future data science
teams to understand what's been done
before and so it's all about
reproducible data science you can
actually do this and help your future
teams find out what's been done before
and they might just find that you've
done something before you learned a load
of things that were non-intuitive the
time and they can save themselves days
or weeks of time of not doing that thing
or just updating your code and making it
a little bit more modern but just
re-running it it's much faster
so i'm going to go through some myths in
today's uh talk federal
is a methodology it's not it's a bunch
of values and it's a bunch of principles
it's not a methodology there are however
lots of different methodologies that
adhere to the agile philosophy uh most
of them uh most people think this is
just scrum but there are other
methodologies available scrum kanban
lean extreme programming you may have
heard some of these things most people
if i ask them they're like yeah
so i'm not gonna be going deep into too
many of these i'm basically just giving
you here is a methodology you can copy
it's what we've implemented in multiple
uh client data teams this year we found
it to work we've really iterated it so
this is our approach to agile agile ish
so a little bit more terminology what is
lean it's the toyota production system
if you read lean startup that's the
toyota production system applied to
companies it's about iterations quick
iterations learning cycles and evolving
your workflows as well kanban visualize
your stories on a board um
through a workflow one nice feature is
limiting the amount of stories limiting
the work and progress you have
factories are really good at doing this
they know that if you've got lots of
stuff piling up then you end up just
doing loads of work managing all the
work and kanban helps to prevent that so
you actually by focusing on doing less
you do more you do use faster
then the scrum which is a very
step-by-step system we're going to be
deep diving into the scrum a little bit
today uh scrum talks about the backlog
this is just all the things you might
want to do but not necessarily have
authorized to do quite yet then there's
your stand-up lots of people do
stand-ups especially in remote working
teams short daily team meetings check
progress although most teams i think do
stand-ups wrong they talk about like
what did the people do today yesterday i
think you should be reviewing your
kanban board where are all the stories
and the items that we're working on and
then the relevant people can speak as to
their progress and the blockers and
what's going on there so there's there's
one little tip
so we're talking about scrum what is
gram it's just a life cycle step by step
by step so uh you have your product
backlog basically your epics your epic
could be deploy my machine learning
model within that epic it's broken down
into a bunch of stories these form your
sprint backlog and so let's say we're
going to select the following stories
we're going to create an api uh version
our data with dvc and deploy to aws
lambda that's what my team is going to
try and achieve in the next two week
sprint so that's our sprint black clock
once selected we go into the sprint
process and that's just um you know very
uh daily quick check-ins but otherwise
letting the team self-organize self-er
stay on top of their own communications
and broadly focus on getting the job
done at the end of that sprint we then
got a working increment of software
so let me give you the meetings and our
agendas please feel free if you've never
tried agile steal these slides and just
literally apply our technique and start
from there so i'm gonna start with myth
number three lots of people think agile
is very undisciplined because lots of
executives in business say yeah we do
agile what they mean is what they're
nimble or they didn't really have a
strategy and they're just pretending
agile is not having strategy this is
nonsense okay so don't fall for it call
people out on that
help educate your leaders and if you're
a leader watching this um
i hope you enjoy this i hope this is
educational if you come and talk to me
i'm very happy to chat further so here
is our agenda for the most important
meeting i think i don't know maybe
retros and more so but sprint planning
the starter sprint maybe 30 minutes
you can adjust this as you go
and so find out what's your resource
availability let's say we've got two
team members alice is available for full
10 days of a two-week sprint uh bob only
two days is uh on holiday uh then what's
your goal our goal for sprint broadly is
we want to deploy our machine learning
model so then we write up our stories we
figure out what are the stories that we
need so we can achieve that goal and
then we select the stories to move into
the sprint then we go through an
estimation process i'm going to go into
this shortly where we estimate how much
effort it's going to be how much value
it's going to be through that we
identify if there's anything that's
huge amounts of effort and high risk
also if there's things that are high
effort low reward let's maybe think
about whether they should be in the
sprint right now and de-scope those
items as appropriate
meeting number two this is the sprint
look ahead this is so we work in
two-week sprints and so every other week
we've got our mid-sprint look ahead and
this is getting into a really nice
productivity tip uh dwight eisenhower
said especially whenever our affair
seems to be in crisis we're almost
compelled to first give our tenants into
the urgent present rather than the
important future so if you've seen the
eisenhower matrix the sprint look ahead
is basically a hack to protect us from
ourselves and focus on the non-urgent
important things it's so much easier to
decide what's important when it's a week
away
in a look ahead versus it's the sprint
starts tomorrow and everything's urgent
right now let's just focus on the urgent
stuff so it's a really nice hack uh i
really recommend trying these out so
you're focusing on just what's happening
in the next sprint not this one we'll
review this one well literally every day
through a 15 minute uh stand up and then
what are the tickets we might want to
add in to capture our higher level
priorities so it's taking a step back
for 10 000 foot view
then we have uh the end of sprint
meeting this is sprint review or if
you've got clients or big stakeholders
you can have a sprint showcase which is
really fun you just get to say right
this is our new iterable working you
know product stage and we review what's
been delivered what's been done what's
not been done is there anything that we
didn't estimate very well
so what do we know it's a forced meeting
that forces you to learn things and
think about how do we improve our
process uh but you celebrate the wins
it's a very celebratory meeting also
just thinking of all the things that are
not yet done do we even have a
definition of done how do we know when
to stop in the world of machine learning
or analytics or r d you can really go
deep into a rabbit hole sometimes so
having a clear definition of done and
sometimes that's literally we're going
to spend one sprint just optimizing this
model we're going to try everything we
can to optimize this model then we're
going to check in see what the model
accuracy and the model performance is
and decide if we want to uh reinvest
another sprint in further optimization
and that's at some point is a
conversation with your stakeholders it's
a business decision uh model uh recall
and precision have gone up by five
percent in the last two weeks of effort
is that worth it for another five
percent from another two weeks it
depends how much that five percent is
worth to the company so it's a really
nice uh flow that i think fits nicely
into into data science teams
then we have the retrospective i
actually think maybe this is the most
important meeting
it's also the one that is most likely to
be skipped so it's your opportunity to
get to with your team and just reflect
uh what's going well what could have
gone better what do we change about our
process the reason i think it's the most
important meeting is because
it doesn't really matter how you start
agile or what form or flavor you choose
as long as you have a retrospective
you're going to have the opportunity to
evolve your process uh to go from four
week sprints to two weeks sprints or
getting rid of your kanban or uh getting
rid of all of scram as long as you have
this you can evolve your process
that's that's the killer part of this
for me uh so the other thing is
be very kind to each other i really
think there's uh a nice thing called the
prime directed by norm kerf regardless
of what we discover we understand and
truly believe that everyone did the best
job they could given what they knew at
the time their skills abilities
resources available and the situation at
hand this uh i've i've learned from as a
fantastic agile company called made tech
in the uk and i really recommend their
book they've got a whole book on agile
team
so
how to run a retro there's a lot more in
that book i'll show that at the end in
my resources
so we've got our four meetings and if
you just start doing those meetings
you're on the way to agile in a big way
like that's almost the whole thing
uh
but one of those was involving adding
estimates into effort and value so how
do we go about doing that okay so myth
number four agile can't meet deadlines
i think that's nonsense okay so agile
projects have been proven to be less
likely to fail proven to have a greater
speed to market why is that well if
you're aiming to do less in each sprint
you actually deliver stuff you get
feedback sooner higher communication uh
which all and all of this is is proven
to be faster turnarounds you get to your
end goal sooner so greater speed to
market you also have higher quality code
your teams are also more motivated and
productive on average this is not a
promise it's just research and
statistics uh have have found this is on
average what agile projects deliver
however i think when it comes to
deadlines you have fixed print cycles
your team gets really good as you get
into your fourth fifth sixth sprint uh
into understanding roughly what can be
done in a two week sprint they get much
better at estimating i can promise you
that between your first print and your
fifth sprint they're going to be way
better at estimating uh what a large
task is versus a small task
about actively thinking through what are
the things that might go wrong here
what's the worst case scenario do i
really know how to deploy something to
aws lambda or am i just being really
over optimistic there
and then you have the review process and
the retro which forces getting even
better at the estimation and
understanding what is capable of
delivering
and you're measuring all of that along
the way so your teams become better at
forecasting how long things will take
the more you do agile which means i
think it's much more likely to deliver
to schedules because you're going to
have more accurate conversations right
up front about what's possible
and if things do come up you've got a
really really fantastic communication
workflow that all of your stakeholders
and your team can understand exactly
where things are through your kanban
boards for example
so that's a little myth
so
how do we do estimation in the face of
uncertainty software is hard enough data
science is
even harder like machine learning
estimation
kind of tricky uh so the trick here is
people are great at relative estimates
so let's say uh here's a couple epic so
we're going to work on this sprint we've
got some stories around deployment and
let's try this really cool new looking
uh light gbm style model that's now in
cycle learn
so what we do
is we first of all estimate our effort
points these are also called story
points i think effort points are
slightly more descriptive so what is an
effort point it's not time it's effort
because someone who's been
i don't know coding for five ten years
is maybe faster at building a faster
api app than someone who's just started
out so it's not time it's effort and you
all agree on relative effort most the
time someone who's built a fast api app
several times i'm pretty sure sebastian
ramirez is going to build a fast api app
faster than i will and so again effort
is not equal to time but it is relative
to each other so
all we say is i recommend t-shirt sizing
small medium large if you have to go
higher but try and keep it relatively um
constrained now you'll notice the
numbering system is a fibonacci sequence
so one two three five eight thirteen why
is that because as we go from large to
extra-large we get really it's really
hard to differentiate between is that
4.5.6 points it's reflecting the
uncertainty of estimating a large task
or a large story it's it's literally
it's impossible so let's uh increase the
increments as we go up those uh those
levels from large to extra large and
beyond
that's a a really really nice system and
has worked well for us
so we've got some effort points in we're
basically saying all of our team agree
that deploying to aws lambda is a really
hard task for us giving our background
on our skills and is much harder than
building the fast api app it's much
harder than uh throwing in dvc into the
system it's much harder than just uh the
the 20 character change of switching our
model out and re-running our test suite
so that's our effort points and if your
teams don't agree
the planning meeting is where you say
okay why do you think that's a one and
you think that's a five maybe there's
something we missed there maybe there's
some uncertainty maybe there's uh things
we didn't anticipate so let's have that
conversation we get better at planning
collaboratively
so your developers or your data science
your team is estimating effort the
stakeholders which is sometimes just the
team manager estimates value and so the
value doesn't always equal the effort
something's really easy to do and just
provide insane amounts of value
something's really hard to do and
they're not that valuable so
again we throw in some value points
along the same system
then we can just calculate a value per
effort score
sort by that score identify some
dependencies or tasks that have to
happen in a certain order and then just
do a rank ordering and this is great
because now for the rest of the sprint
my team can just start taking tasks from
the top knowing that they're working on
the most valuable work given the effort
and the tasks near the bottom they're
more like the nice to haves
there's more effort the less value
so self-organizing teams that requires
much less management through that sprint
cycle
now if you're first implementing this
for the first time sprint number one
don't worry about this like just make up
the numbers and see what happens uh
review at the end calculate the total
effort points completed
and then calculate what we call a
velocity score which is how many effort
points did you complete in your sprint
cycle or per day and that gives you your
rough estimate as to how many effort
points do we even put on the board for
the next sprint
and you're going to get better once you
start tracking your velocity you're
going to get better at tracking more
tasks and also there's a really curious
effect your velocity is going to go up
over time so this is uh velocity and
value delivered by my operations team um
over over the last few months and what's
happened here is we've got better at
prioritizing more high impact work
better roi work is going to be sprint
and the lower uh value work is uh maybe
being uh delayed until later or even
just we're realizing it's not as high
value as everything else we're doing at
the moment so an amazing thing starts to
happen now this will tell the first time
as you just get really good at
consistently delivering high value work
uh but uh this is something you will
grow to become accustomed to what is
your velocity
uh for a team of two people maybe six
years at points in two weeks
do you take into account half status law
it always takes longer than you expect
even when you're into taking into
account hof status law
top tip okay so segueing into some more
practical tips and tricks to learn from
the last 12 months of me trying this out
as a total newcomer so uh stories can
roll over into the next point you
haven't finished something just roll
over don't try and get your team to
finish everything in time uh communicate
upwards really carefully send people
this video uh and just understand that
things change bugs happen data science
is hard it's literally research and
development uh allow for that
uncertainty uh don't make your teams
burn out trying to just hit their sprint
deadlines that's crazy uh discuss why
your teams underestimated these things
revise the effort points going to the
next sprint learn from that become
better at forecasting and it all ends up
sort of in the wash over several sprints
you're going to claim the points in the
next print it doesn't matter
uh daily stand up make it about the
items not the people and also lots of
people do stand-ups like first thing in
the morning consider other times have a
conversation with your team is 9 a.m
really the best time for your team maybe
they just want to come into work and
just crack on with the thing that they
were halfway through when they finished
yesterday uh so we do a midday stand up
uh which we learned from another london
startup works really well for us
okay use spikes if you're not sure about
how long something's going to take don't
spend forever trying to estimate it use
a fixed time box window say
okay we don't know how to deploy onto a
google cloud function we've never done
that before uh we don't know how to
estimate how long that will take so what
we're going to do is a three hour spike
this one person's gonna go and just
spend three hours researching it
effectively that's enough time we think
into how long it's gonna take to know
how long it will take to then go ahead
and do that or to break it down into the
right stories so if you can't estimate
things uh just build the uncertainty and
that's a three-hour spike a three-point
story in your board
never skip retro
it's too valuable it's your optimization
process
and your teams
will not forgive you if you skip this
continuously over and over again it
doesn't matter how important the
deadlines are uh this is an investment
in your team's future productivity
i think it's really nice idea to align
your epics with quarters as in have a
definition of done on your epics if you
use akrs it works really well at okrs it
forces you to actually look at the big
headline stories that you're looking at
and say do we actually still want to do
this is this still valuable for business
or have we now just spent three months
trying to build a machine learning model
for one-shot learning and it turns out
this is really hard and it's like a
we need a whole research team of uh phds
and postdocs to achieve this and maybe
we bit off more than we can chew so
conscious story rollover it also is an
opportunity to re-prioritize and
readdress your technical debt that may
have gained in the quarter
of evolve your system through retros
let your team innovate they will
understand how to be more productive for
themselves and finally don't try to
replicate someone else's agile type not
you know
make it your own
your company's culture is unique your
team's culture is unique so just let
things evolve and learn what works for
you
okay so some tools of the trade
this is what we've used this is what
works well for us if you're just
wondering where to start we use gitlab
predominantly for our own internal work
but we use jira github projects um for
client work we've done some zenhub work
and zenhub is a
like a github
chrome plugin that sort of does stuff on
github and then they've got their own
service so it's a really nice agile
project management tool for github
and i've dabbled with that and i think
that actually looks really nice so uh
it's a hardcore between gitlab and
zenhub because nhub has all the effort
points and value points built into it as
well as things like planning poker
spreadsheets we use a lot of because we
can just automate the connections of
data between like github apis into
spreadsheets and then uh this works
really well for stuff at gitlab or
whatever tool we're using for the client
doesn't work so well we can just throw
the data in capture the effort points in
the value points from the client sort by
our our value scoring and off we go
also means we can do all the analytics
on top we actually use monday for our
agile operations we use range is really
going to discover this last quarter for
async stand-ups meeting automation okr
tracking and then metro retro is my
favorite tool for retrospectives don't
just do retros with like a notebook or
meeting notes or whatever use a proper a
retro tool like miro or metro retro it's
fun confetti at the end is great
okay so myth number five agile is for
software teams it's absolutely not um
marketing agile uh uh is is uh
increasingly popular agile ups is also
increasingly popular here is a little
insight into how we do agile within our
own startup operations and it works
really well uh our team is really
enjoying it we're moving faster we're
delivering more we've got the kanban
board there if you've gone ops team and
you want to replicate our little board
we can just talk to us and and uh we'll
give that away for you
okay so last few minutes uh advice for
leaders so if you are running a team uh
i'm speaking to you now and if you are a
member of team uh again send this video
to your to your senior leaders if you
like the idea of agile and
this is my advice so first of all agile
is for startups total myth okay john
deere huge tractor farming manufacturer
implemented agile years ago they saw 75
reduction in their project cycle times
developing machines from uh eight months
instead of sort of two three years
uh their teams were happier much happier
uh the velocity how much work you're
doing per sprint increased 2x 3x 5x 9x
uh amazing improvement and just
productivity and it's not just quantity
of quality they actually were able to
prove their quality also measurably
improved so there's a really fantastic
for your team leaders um article on
harvard business review which i've
linked to here called embracing agile
with loads more of these case studies
also agile is the best practice delivery
standard for uk government projects uh
one of my other favorite resources is
the gov uk uh service delivery manual on
agile delivery step-by-step 101 to agile
so here's my advice for your leaders
lead with questions not with orders okay
don't tell your teams how you want
things done let them figure that out
tell them what you'd like to do
if it's good enough for george patton
it's good enough for me uh guide them
with the questions understand how could
we test these things how are we going to
measure this
and through doing so you will grow your
technical leads and becoming better
general managers
don't switch to agile too quickly 63 of
the organizations that failed in agile
is most often because of clashes between
business culture and agile philosophy so
don't switch your entire companies out
on one go do it in small batches uh send
everyone the video see who's interested
start there iterate learn tweak adapt
your process uh build success stories in
terms of inside your company and uh just
iterate be lean use agile to do agile so
final tips and tricks uh next steps
recommended reading
made tech have great written this great
book it's free online downloadable ebook
uh building high performance agile teams
i've learnt so much from that book
of just how to get things done
then the phoenix project i just think is
really fun it's a novel it's kind of
funny kind of painful because it's so
close to home
and
if you get the book version it includes
a devops handbook in the back which is
then like a really like step-by-step
checklist and the agile service delivery
manual as i as i mentioned
finally i'll leave this load up a moment
longer uh bit.these false launch pi data
hyphen
agile and you can see just a little
table of contents this is uh just uh
opened up our own playbook because this
is an article competency we do
analytics and data and machine learning
and stuff but we've learned all of this
and i'm quite happy to try and share it
so what you get here is sort of
step-by-step agendas notes about how to
do this well uh we're continually adding
to this we have just a very agile lean
process about how we run our own
internal operations and then all of the
tricks and the links and i'll put this
video once it's available publicly i'll
put this video link there as well
so thank you very much uh you can
find out our details here feel free to
reach out to us if you want to talk to
me about anything i've talked about
today and otherwise have a great supply
date of global i will be in the gala
afterwards to take questions hand in the
slacks
thank you very much for your
for your nice talk i'm sure that all of
the attendees enjoyed and also learned
many things
excellent i am screenshotting all of
these questions and i'll answer them in
the slack somewhere awesome
awesome thank you very much john
you